alright we're trying this again let me
know this is working is it working and
you see me we had a bit of a hiccup
that's not foo the first round o people
can see yes no yes no no yes yes no
there yeah yeah I know what happened on
that first one guy that was crazy anyway
we're here let's extend it a little bit
this time around so we can get it going
gratitude journal live stream number
this should be 33 its marked as test
some hiccups on YouTube this morning um
we share three things will get before
i'm going to start it off with mine you
guys share it in the live chat I'll go
to the old live chat to to pull some of
those in and I want you guys to think as
you're going through this how do I make
it a daily habit if you're joining me
here every every morning 9am East and
that's awesome if you're doing on your
own that's great but make it a
consistent habit and then just one one
step further on the three things you're
grateful for what what is the reason
behind it what's the why why are you
grateful for just that extra little
question helps it sink in helps you feel
the emotional benefit to help you be a
happy entrepreneur instead of only focus
on what you don't have also realizing
that you're putting fortunate you got a
lot of great things in your life right
now so I'm gonna start with mine I'm uh
I'm grateful for my wife Nina here she
is for a lot of things but especially
what I'm thinking about today she's had
super busy week she's been waking up
before the Sun has come up and it's put
in then and she has meetings downtown
and then has a full day of work and and
then in some cases like I'm Monday she
had to go then teach it turn that's also
for another four hours and so just out
the whole day uh and she didn't complain
about anything
right just like she's right I got to do
I'm going to go do it and not
complaining in that wine and not say no
I'm so tired i know they wake up so
early and and I just I I respect that a
lot I mean I love a lot of things about
Nina but that's one of them is that the
not really complaining about things when
work has to get done she just goes out
and does it and so I'm grateful for that
mindset and attitude that she has um I'm
people for razors I shaved that last
night and just thinking razors out what
would we do without razors we'd have to
sharpen knives or pluck hairs or I don't
know I'm just super grateful for
disposable razors that can help us shave
so quickly I'm given for the lawn my
number three is the lawn he's my
security guard downstairs and he's a
super nice guy I've lived in this
building before and he's been one of my
favorite guys that's that's gonna ever
been here it's on the at the building
just easy easy going super friendly you
know given fist bumps thinking about me
when packages come in he asked me to be
a reference for him today give me an
email is a 10-month says that he's been
here he's trying to get a raise so his
performance reviews coming up so I'm a
pretty good reference to give him a good
job so I'm just reminded me how quick
volume for the dough being able to go
downstairs and know that there's
somebody positive and happy and you can
have a good conversation with makes me
grateful and then quit number forwards
video day I forgot it's Wednesday it's
video day I get to record for the
YouTube channel I'm pumped okay let's
get to you I'm gonna I'm gonna go what
do you guys want you to go to the old
chat first or should I just start with a
new chat quick votes quick votes old
chat first our new chat because I want
to respect what you guys have put in
there before but I see the new chat
blowing up let's do some quick quick old
chat first let's see we got to Zino
leading us off super happy about
hello party people believe nation I know
you all something be grateful for what
are they nathanville said Xena with an
early opening BAM may fulfill script
before Evans thunderclap that makes me
laugh and pump at the same time I like
that I like it's become hashtag
thunderclap grateful for my new client
and all the great projects he bring to
the table congratulations people for
finally fixing a nasty bug hashtag web
dev love that man zayna's gave up for a
good night's sleep I didn't sleep well
the last couple nights and had been
super tired throughout the day the last
time I slept as well as I can hope for I
love that congratulations at good
night's sleep solid people who are
people who are willing to provide
feedback knows obliged to do so and I'm
really happy they're willing to spend
their time to help me awesome and
external hard drives for extra memory
because I absolutely need it this is a
really great clip we have coming up with
David Allen who's talking about the
brain or the mind and you're saying it's
not meant to be I'm not going to do it
justice it's not meant to be a storage
device it's meant to be creative device
and so it when you have ideas when
you're so focused when you have so much
in your head that you you know just try
to remember everything then you have no
space for creativity so to be able to
get it off your head into an external
hard drive somewhere right your computer
Evernote something get out of your head
into there so that you can free up your
mind to be able to do more creative
stuff how those interesting watch the
top 10 of David Allen because he put it
way better than I did but I found that
point really interesting at least point
number four my favorite point of the
video Jay rises thankful for my
awareness and tension to detail for my
parents who always support me and for
Bieber for living a public life at a
young age for toilet paper it's an it's
a great invention seriously that really
is a great adventure yes g arises a mod
yes it is a mod congratulations Jay your
eyes what we got Melissa good morning is
cool today the Caribbean cool cool today
what's cool let's see it's got to be
relative que el bien grateful for the
opportunity to teach medical students
techniques and tips
past the most important exam of their
lives love it to the skilled jetblue
pilot because their trip to Orlando was
nice and smooth turbulence free are you
in our land know that how you guys
joining from Orlando that's pretty
awesome and three people receiving great
news today still don't know what it is
yet I like that grateful for the future
good news that I know is coming today
the Diagon let that one sink in I like
that that's that's a great mindset
coming up there okay I'm gonna hop over
to the new chat see we got going on here
sue med Evans sir I request you take
some kickstart sessions on meditation I
haven't been able to metod I've been on
an off meditation for years I see all
these people talk about the benefits
I've never felt it I've tried with
guided sessions I've tried with
headspace I've tried with a whole bunch
of different things I just don't feel
the benefit when I when I go through it
I don't I don't I don't I don't I don't
know maybe maybe I'm ready Zen enough I
don't know i don't i don't feel the
benefit so i would love to this is so
many studies and everything on it but I
just I haven't gotten into it a new
future bill are grateful for all the
good and bad that has happened in my
life that has got me to this point I
love that Rishi I'm grateful for all
innovators and pioneers who pay the way
for others before that we are never
alone wow I like this on Rishi 3
grateful for New Mexico haven't been yet
but I'm going alright Nina is in the
house saying hi rishi people are
freaking out Nina booboo Nina I right
Nina welcome aboard Nina if you watch
back to the start you'll see that I'm
people for you you can see why people
want more recipes a bunch of chatter let
me go back to the top and see what we
have what are people great before
buh-buh-buh a couple of repeats best you
Pro vehicle for technology I like it
grateful for the opportunity to share
our knowledge with the world through our
website and three great before the
belief
community hashtag believe nation I'm
super grateful for you guys super people
sooo mad gay prefer my book library from
which I'm getting unfathomable knowledge
I love that and YouTube channels to
hashtag leave nation I love that but we
got when we got old chat new chat old
Chad Elizabeth watch all the time first
time live welcome aboard Elizabeth
grateful for Evan and all of you happy
rising hurt that here I love it we rise
together we rise it's a Jay Reise thing
I love it what do we else what else what
else we have Nina I just found my way
here to this channel welcome aboard Nina
welcome on the new channel your
subscriber number I don't know 70 what
quick check of the subscribers what do
we have what do we have dashboard how
many subscribers how many subscribers
whatever yet 74 subscribers Nina you are
number 74 thank you guys all right it's
914 we still got our 10 minutes in thank
you guys for joining me we're gonna hop
over to twitch now and play a game of
League of Legends while answering your
business questions I hope you'll join us
there if not have an amazing day I
believe in you guys I hope that you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon